If there's other pathways that are important, vitamin D receptor pathway, that's very important
for patients.
If they have a lot of defects of that pathway, they need to be tated by a molecule, they
need to be tated higher, vitamin D level, then clinically what would be considered clinically
normal.
There's cell membrane protection genes, this can lead to cancer, this is a very important
gene right here.
The sex horrible vinyne blog gene for women, especially.
So women in their teens and 20s that have a defect on this gene are going to be much more
susceptible to menstrual issues, PMS issues, if you have a double allele defect, the chance
of you having ovarian cysts and breast cysts is much greater because it affects your ability
to hold progesterone.
It's here progesterone issues.
It's actually quite treatable, so no way that you have that gene, no way that your 8-year-old
girl has that gene, you could really help prevent a lot of stuff with her, so that could be
really helpful.
In every woman that I've ever tested that I've had that gene defect that I mentioned, just
what I said goes, oh my gosh, I've had, you know, I think every woman that I've ever
had, I've had a very sensitive, I had the worst PMS issues today, so I think it's very
clinically relevant.
Single mutations get to increase the risk of it.
And then this iron oxidation panel is really, I think, important, this person doesn't have
a lot of defects there, it's very important, that's something that's really high with
my patients, this iron oxidation panel, their iron is being oxidized, so they have symptoms
of anemia, and the worst thing they can do is go on more iron.
So it's just, it's being oxidized, so there's some specific nutrients that you could help
with that.
So that is extremely helpful, clinically symptomatically, that could cause a majority of the person's
symptoms too.
With cancer patients, we almost always see MUTL homolog gene defects.
So there's just some of the things that are common with cancer and not common with Lyme,
Fysomersa, those are DNA repair genes, the urea cycle I just mentioned in PASA before, but
that's how you get rid of ammonia in your body.
So if you're producing excess ammonia with CBS defects, that's the transalpheration pathway,
you're not getting rid of it through the kidney very well, you're going to have excess
ammonia issues, also with certain, especially the anyl acid gene I think it is in here,
you will have an increase in your risk of kidney stones, so you've got to make sure it's
your staying hydrated.